I think one of the most memorable
moments was when I first saw her,
cause uh,
you know,
I had seen many pictures,
many videos of earth from space and
being able to see that with my own eyes
had a completely different effect and
sort of almost sensing life emanating
from our planet in the dark background
of the space.
It was a really memorable experience.
I wasn't frightened.
I've been living this in my head for
many,
many years.
So,
um,
I've sort of had played all these
scenarios,
have flying to spacing earth and I think
I was very prepared for it.
So it was almost a completely a joyful,
very happy,
very exciting experience.
And I didn't have time or you know,
any desire to think about what things
could go wrong.
Well,
I'm the first designer,
uh,
which is a design that won the Ansari x
prize that was designed by,
well Javier and space has been
commercialized by Virgin Galactic.
Uh,
right now I think their plans are for
the first commercial flights to take
place in 2012.
So it's not that far away.
And I think from there we will see a lot
more competition.
And I know many other companies are
building,
uh,
you know,
designing a new spacecraft for orbital
and snowboard resolve flights.
So as soon as we see competition and
we'll see the prices come down and
really an industry being created,
I think space travel is a dream for many
men and women.
Um,
I think it,
you know,
my trip will be perceived differently by
different genders because uh,
for women,
uh,
a lot of time not only,
you know,
space travel,
it's not accessible to everyone,
but this even less accessible to women,
they're a lot more barriers for them,
especially if they live in countries
where things like space travel
engineering,
uh,
any science and technology related
fields would be considered a more male
dominated male appropriate field.
So I want to show them that there is
nothing preventing women or making them
less qualified to be involved in any of
these fields.
But the equally,
I think men also get very interested
because as I said,
the space is not accessible today.
Too many people.
And one of my goals as my involvement
through and sorry,
x prize was to create the opportunity
for everyone equally,
men and women.
I say that a woman's right is definitely
a key issue because you also see a woman
actually in a way being very,
very active in this movement.
Um,
it has been an issue,
um,
you know,
over the past,
uh,
you know,
years and,
uh,
the situation sort of fluctuates.
Sometimes it's um,
gets a little bit easier and it gets
harder again.
And uh,
overall I think,
uh,
women in Iran are very resilient and I'm
very proud of all the Iranian woman that
are sending up for the rights and
speaking out.
And,
uh,
I hope that they will succeed and I'm
glad that the international community is
paying attention and supporting them as
well.
At Protea.
Uh,
what do you want it to do is build a
platform to be able to deliver Internet
based application to the users,
um,
in sort of a mass market environment
regardless of their skill sets or where
they live.
And you want it to do that so they can
consume the information or the
experience or the application to any
media,
that medium that they are used to using,
whether it's a mobile or the TV or their
pc or any other devices that could be
created in a ubiquitous manner and
making information and services,
uh,
ubiquitously and simply available to
everyone will actually close the digital
gap that exists today between
generations sometimes and create new
opportunities actually for current
application service providers to address
a bit much larger market place and be
able to design applications that are
more suited for this larger audience.